رغم فشل اجتماع الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ورئيسي مجلس النواب كبن مكارتي بالتوصل
الى اتفاق حول سقف الدين التفاؤل موجود
الى طاوله التفاوض اكد انه ما يعملان على
التوصل الى حل وسط بشان الميزانيه قبل
الاول من يونيو
الجمهوريون القوا باللوم على الرئيس بايدن
واعاد اتهامه بالتاخر في اجراء المفاوضات
مع مكارتي واكدوا تمسكهم بشروطهم كما اوضح
زعيمهم في مجلس النواب
الذي رايناه في الايام القليله الماضيه من
جو بايدن هو الاستمرار في تضييع الوقت
وليس تقديم افكار جاده على طاوله
المفاوضات في الواقع تقديم افكار جديده
غير مالوفه الرئيس يتحدث عن زياده الضرائب
لقد اوضحنا منذ البدايه اننا لن نرفع
الضرائب
في المقابل اعتبر رئيس التجمع الديمقراطي
في مجلس النواب ان الجمهوريين محتجزون من
قبل الجناح المتطرف في حزبهم
الديموقراطيون في مجلس النواب على
التخفيضات المدمره للمساعدات الغذائيه
للمعلمين او التخفيف يحتاج رئيس مجلس
النواب مكارثي الى ان يكون جادا الطرفان
متمسكان بشروطهما ويتبادلان التهمه حول
ازمه الدين الذي ارتفع نحو خمسه
التريليونات دولار عام 2000 الى اكثر من
31 تريليون دولار هذا العام
اذا عدت الى الفتره التي كان فيها الرئيس
كلينتون في منصبه ثم غادره فقد ترك في
الواقع فائضا بمئات ملايين الدولارات التي
اعدها جورج w الى الاغنياء عبر التخفيضات
الضريبيه ثم بدات حرب العراق وافغانستان
بزياده العيش الى الرقم اليوم وادى الركود
عام 2008 الى تفاقم المشكله ولعل الحل
الوحيد المتبقي للازمه الحاليه وفق خبراء
هو رفع موجز لسقف الدين لفتره زمنيه محدده
لاعطاء مزيد من الوقت للطرفين لمواصله
العمل على القضيه يدور الحديث الان في
واشنطن على ان المشرعين قد يبقون في
العاصمه خلال عطله نهايه الاسبوع الطويله
التي تتزامن مع عيد العمال من اجل التوصل
الى حل للازمه حسين الطوط العربيه واشنطن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات